les négociations entre les participants
au dialogue interlibyen ont donc abouti
dans un lieu tenu secret en suisse
ils ont désigné un candidat surprise
adoul hamid behbahani tenu trente neuf
fois sur 73 originaires de misrata cet
ingénieur a notamment présidé la
compagnie libyenne d'investissement et
de développement sous le règne de
mouammar kadhafi
ce premier ministre désigné devra dans
un délai ne dépassant pas 20 jours
former son gouvernement selon l'onu il
aura également la lourde tâche de
réunifier les institutions et
d'organiser les élections nationales
programmée le 24 décembre prochain
nous surveillerons ce que vous avez
désigné pour nous assurer qu'ils
rendront le pouvoir au peuple les biens
le 24 décembre de cette année afin
d'élire démocratiquement les
représentants et les dirigeants
politiques de la libye
si la désignation du nouveau premier
ministre marque d'avancé la situation
politique libyenne reste chaotique deux
autorités se disputent toujours les
rênes du pays
d'un côté le gouvernement d'union
nationale reconnue par l'onu et jusqu
alors dirigé par faïza sa rage de
l'autre à pouvoir incarner parlera lifar
tard l'homme soutenue par le parlement
de tobrouk qui contrôlent l'est du
territoire
après de nombreux affrontements les deux
camps ont conclu un cessez le feu en
octobre dernier pour s'assurer d'une
transition réussie en libye le conseil
de sécurité a ordonné le déploiement
d'observateurs sur place onze mois avant
la tenue d'un scrutin crucial pour
l'avenir du pays